[Music]
Poland is changing every year the
country celebrates its National
Independence Day in the capital of
Warsaw there are parades and speeches
but in 2017
Poland's Independence Day made worldwide
news because of these signs
60,000 people showed up for a March led
by nationalists and white supremists
that's because they have reason to
celebrate to Poland's right-wing
political party peace is in power after
winning the presidency and a majority in
parliament they've ignored the
Constitution taken over the courts
purged the military and crack down on
the media pieces bringing
authoritarianism back to Poland and
openly rebelling against the European
Union it's a shocking turn for a country
that just a few years ago was hailed as
one of Europe's most promising young
democracies so how did this happen and
can it be stopped
[Music]
it was an old story to the people of
Poland conquest subjugation enslavement
it had happened before in Poland's
troubled history but never was such in
humanity Poland had a traumatic 20th
century it was invaded twice during
World War two first by the Germans and
then by the Soviets who reestablished
the country after the war but as a
communist state under their control in
fact a Soviet dictator Joseph Stalin
directly contributed to a draft of
Poland's Constitution which was
formalized in 1952
these are his handwritten notes for the
next several decades Poland developed
very little while it was cut off from
the rest of the world it became one of
several Soviet backed communist
countries in Central and Eastern Europe
that made up the Soviet bloc that
started to change in the 1980s Polish
unions started organizing huge strikes
against communist government the
movement came to be called solidarity
and it grabbed the attention of the
whole world as part of the International
Day of Solidarity with the people of
Poland we send them this message behind
their wall of silence in this time of
despair we hold out this candle of hope
in 1989 the communist government caved
to the pressure and agreed to let non
communist parties run in the elections
solidarity and Democratic candidates
went on to win the majority of
Parliament and the presidency they
established the Republic of Poland and
became the first country in Europe to
topple communism the rest of the Soviet
bloc soon followed
[Music]
this posed a challenge for Western
Europe when that union will be a tree
since the end of World War two the
continents democracies had been growing
closer signing free trade deals that
became the precursor to today's European
Union at first the trade deals just
covered coal and steel but as they grew
to include agriculture energy and other
markets more countries joined making
Europe more economically and politically
integrated than it had ever been before
as the former Soviet bloc countries
started establishing democracies of
their own Western Europe needed to find
a way to include them so in 1993 the
established EU countries came up with a
strict checklist for admitting new
members new member states needed to have
a free-market economy
respect human rights and the rule of law
that meant courts had to be independent
and impartial so everyone could get a
fair trial
these EU rules helped bring former
communist countries in while also
keeping them from sliding back into
authoritarianism they were designed to
keep the peace in Europe Poland joined
the EU in 2004 and because of solidarity
success it became one of the most
promising new members each year after it
joined Poland received millions of euros
to help fund highways schools hospitals
and modern infrastructure but 2014
Poland became one of the EU strongest
and most resilient members it even
avoided the recession in 2009 that
crippled economies worldwide polling
showed 72% of poles were satisfied with
EU membership more than any other member
state and Poland's charismatic pro EU
Prime Minister Donald Tusk was chosen to
become the president of the EU European
Council
but in his absence leaders with a very
different vision for Poland's future
rose to power in 2015 peace Poland's
right-wing party shocked the world and
won an absolutely
in the parliament since 2001 peace had
been led by former solidarity leaders
lack and yaroslav coach in ski who felt
that poland's center-left parties had
become elitist and corrupt it appealed
to poland's conservative population in
rural areas peace only earned 38% of the
vote in 2015 on par with previous
election results but after tests left
for the EU his coalition fell apart
making room for the right-wing party to
take over
according to peace after decades of
Soviet control Poland was now being
controlled by the EU so when it came to
power it pledged to take back Poland's
independence legally or illegally the
party already controlled both houses of
parliament and the presidency so it
initiated a hostile takeover of the
judicial branch first to pack this
constitutional court with loyal judges
and then forced out more than a third of
the judges in this other court both acts
were illegal under the Polish
Constitution but the peace majority
Parliament and presidency signed them
into law anyway the party also fired
over 11,000 civil service workers and at
least 280 military officers and it
started levelling fines on news
organizations when it didn't like their
coverage meanwhile has been using Polish
nationalisms justify these moves
remember this 2017 controversial March a
peace politician called it a beautiful
sight while the party cracked down on
protests against their authoritarian
moves as peace tightened control on
Poland the EU issued several warnings to
stop it from breaking its rules but
peace ignored them
it is with a heavy heart that we have
decided to initiate article 7 1 but the
facts leave us no choice
in December 2017 the EU invoked article
7 its nuclear option for the first time
in its history it allows the EU to strip
a member of its voting rights if it
feels it's breaking their criteria
established in 1993 a significant
numbers of laws have been adopted 13 in
total which put at serious risk the
Independence of the judiciary and the
separation of powers in Poland the
problem for the EU is that article 7
isn't going to work the punishment
requires a unanimous vote by all EU
countries and there's one country that
has sworn to protect Poland Hungary
another former Soviet bloc country has
taken a turn towards authoritarianism
under President Viktor Orban and he
vowed to veto any punishment against
Poland pieces proving that it's possible
to reap the economic benefits of EU
membership while flouting the rule of
law and that has sparked an existential
crisis for the EU the rules that were
written to prevent authoritarianism from
ever reappearing in Europe aren't being
followed and there's not much I can do
about it
the you could try cutting off Poland's
funding but it's unclear how that would
pass so for now the EU remains in a
crisis for decades has tried to keep
Europe Democratic but Poland once used
most promising new addition is
threatening to undermine the whole thing
[Music]
[Music]